PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ARCHULETA ATKINS BASICS OCCUR
FORTUS BRADFORD CABALLERO
CORTES DE DALLY GOD ROSSUM
AIKMAN LASER GUNS ALLAH'S ROVE
HERTZBERG WAY SO HER TADO.
JONES CAN LONGER LAYERED EVA
THE MOON MCGUIRE MELINDA'S MEN
NEWMAN NIELSEN OCHO A BOGUS PAN
FORTUNE TINO RALPH RUBIO
SKINNER STERN AMBERG BY CAL SKI
WINNER WILL. THANK YOU MA'AM
SIR TERRY OF A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE
LED IN PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
SENATOR I'M BERG AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WILL BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
BY SENATOR ARCHULETA. SEREMBAN
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES MERCIFUL GOD WHO
DESIRES THAT ALL SHOULD BE FREE.
THIS PAST WEEKEND WE REMEMBER
THAT SEVENTY SEVEN YEARS AGO
AMERICAN SOLDIERS ANOTHER
ALLIED FORCES LANDED PARACHUTED
INTO NORMANDY. OPEN TO BRING AN
END TO WORLD WAR TWO IN EUROPE.
WE PRAY IN GRATITUDE FOR THOSE
WHO GAVE THEIR LIVES FOR OUR
FREEDOM WE PRAY IN GRATITUDE
FOR WORLD WAR TWO VETERANS AND
FOR ALL VETERANS DEDICATED TO
PROTECTING OUR FREEDOMS TODAY.
WE PRAY IN GRATITUDE FOR THE
MANY FREEDOMS WE POSSESS
FREEDOM OF RELIGION SPEECH THE
PRESS FREEDOM TO ASSEMBLE AND
PETITION AND FREEDOM TO CAST
OUR VOTE. GOD OF MERCY GRANT US
THE COURAGE AND FORTITUDE TO
PERSEVERE IN BRINGING TO
FRUITION IN OUR LIFETIME OUR
DEEPEST DESIRES FOR LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL WE ASK THIS IN
YOUR NAME. AMEN. YOUR HONOR THE
MEN AND WOMEN WHO FOUGHT AND
DIED IN NORMANDY. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. IT IS A
LITTLE. STRONG. THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN. MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE
DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WILL BE
DEEMED RED AND I'M AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS WISHING TO BE
RECOGNIZED UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. SEEING NONE
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR JUNE FIRST THROUGH
THIRD. TWO THOUSAND TO TWENTY
ONE WILL BE APPROVED AND
CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE CLERK.
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES CENTER
LAYERED. ARE YOU READY. HI M.
S. THANK YOU SIR. WELL THE
FIRST ONE IS FINALIZED IN TO
WHAT'S THE CONFIRMATION OF
KATHLEEN ALLISON THE SECRETARY
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
SHE BEGAN HER CAREER AT CDC R.
AS A MEDICAL TECHNICAL
ASSISTANT IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN. SHE HAS SERVED IN A
NUMBER OF MANAGEMENT POSITIONS
INCLUDING WARDEN DIRECTOR OF
DIVISION OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS
AND UNDERSECRETARY OF
OPERATIONS SHE'S BREAKING A
GLASS CEILING SHE WAS APPROVED
BY THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE
ON APRIL FOURTEENTH ON A FOUR
TO ZERO VOTE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN IPHONE. THANK YOU
SENATOR LARRY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS APPOINTEE
SENATOR DELHI. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS I LIKE TO
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY JUST TO
SPEAK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
KATHLEEN WHO HAVE JUST GOTTEN A
KNOWN- UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE
THERE IS A CLOSURE OF- PRISONS
RIGHT THE DAY BEFORE. SHE WAS
CONFIRMED- BUT SHE GOT HER
HEARING IN FRONT OF A- THE OF
THE- RULES COMMITTEE SO I WANT%
TO SHARE SURE FIRST OFF THANK
THE RULES COMMITTEE FOR
ADDRESSING THE QUESTIONS I HAD
THE PRO TEM. FOR MAKING SURE I
HAD- THOSE QUESTIONS- IN
WRITING TO ME AND I WANTED TO
SHARE THAT- SINCE THAT TIME.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH
HER AND IF SHE DID NOT
INDIVIDUALLY MAKE THESE
DECISIONS OVER THEY WERE MADE
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION ON
HERSELF. AND IT GREATLY
AFFECTED MY COMMUNITY SO TODAY
I'M GOING TO BE LAYING OFF I
WANTED TO SAY THAT SHE HAS BEEN
VER OPEN TRANSPARENT AND
ACCESSIBLE. ALONG WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE BUT TO THE
WOUNDS TO MY COMMUNITY HAVE
BEEN- ARE STILL RAW AND THERE
WE ARE LOSING- SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN A- EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND JOBS IN OUR COMMUNITY
SO I JUST WANT TO SHARE WITH
THE- LEGISLATORS TODAY THAT-
I'LL BE LAYING OFF BUT SHE HAS
BEEN VERY OPEN AND TRANSPARENT
AND I. LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH HER ON THAT THE CHALLENGES
WE'RE GOING TO BE FACED WITH.
OVER THE NEXT FIVE YEAR WITHIN
FIVE YEARS WITH THE RELEASE OF
MANY MORE INMATES IN OUR SYSTEM
SO THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS. THANK YOU SENATOR
DALEY CENTER COME LONGER. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT- YOU KNOW AS A
MEMBER OF THE RULES COMMITTEE I
VOTED FOR MISS LLISON BECAUSE
I WANTED TO GRANT HER- THE
COURTESY OF BEING HEARD ON THE
FULL FLOOR I ACTUALLY- HAD A
VERY ROBUST DISCUSSION WITH HER
PRIOR TO THE INTERVIEW AND
RULES AND- SPOKE WITH HER FOR
PROBABLY. OVER AN HOUR ASKING
SOME VERY HARD QUESTIONS- ABOUT
CDC ARE- AND WHAT'S HAPPENING
YOU KNOW I AM WILL NOT BE
VOTING TODAY ON THIS
APPOINTMENT- THIS IS MIKE MY
CONSCIENCE GUIDING ME IT HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH ANY ONE
PARTICULAR PERSON. BUT IT
SPEAKS TO A REAL FACT THAT IF
WE ARE GOING TO WORK TO CHANGE
A SYSTEM THEN WE CANNOT PLACATE
IT BY REALLY ALLOWING PEOPLE.
TO MOVE AROUND MY DECK CHAIRS-
ON A TITANIC YOU KNOW CDC ARE
IS A BROKEN SYSTEM AND IF YOU
HAVE READ ANY OF THE ARTICLES
IN THE RECENT WEEKS- PEOPLE ARE
LITERALLY DYING EMPLOYEES AND
INCARCERATED FOLKS. AND I THINK
WE NEED TO HAVE A VERY HONEST
DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW WE RE
IMAGINE A SYSTEM THAT DOES NOT
FORCE FOLKS WHO WORK THERE. TO
KILL THEMSELVES OR. TO BEGIN TO
ENGAGE IN. HARMFUL ACTIVITIES-
OF SELF HARM SO THAT THEY CAN
CONTINUE WORKING I THINK WE
HAVE TO HAVE A REAL DIALOGUE
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING INSIDE
OF THESE PRISONS. BECAUSE AT
THE END OF THE DAY THAT BLOOD.
THAT SPILLS. IS ON OUR HANDS SO
I AM JUST REITERATING THAT THIS
IS MY CONSCIENCE SPEAKING TO ME
ABOUT THE FACT THAT THIS IS A
BROKEN SYSTEM AND WE ARE ASKING
FOLKS TO STEP INTO IT. AND TRY
TO MAKE IT WORK. AND IT'S THE
WAY. I HAVE NO WORDS BUT I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY- TO SHARE ASSETS
WILL BE SOLD THEIR CONSCIENCE
THANK YOU CENTER COME UNDER
CENTER CALLED AERO. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT- I'M GOING SUPPORT
THIS THIS- APPOINTMENT TODAY
BUT I JUST FELT LIKE I HAD TO
SAY THAT- THEY'RE ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE GOING
FORWARD IS THAT WE'VE WE'VE- WE
ARE FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGING CDC
ARE AND WE'RE CHANGING. THE WAY
THAT WE'RE DOING BUSINESS AND
IT'S GOING TO TAKE TIME BUT A
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO. PRISONS
WERE SOLD TO RURAL CALIFORNIA
AS A AS AN ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. TOOL FOR THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND SO. IN MANY IN
MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES PRISONS
ARE PAID THE HIGHEST WAGES IN
THE REGION WE HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT WORK FORCE. LIVE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AND TO BECOME
PART OF OUR COMMUNITY SO IF AND
WHEN WE'RE GOING TO MAKE
REDUCTIONS IN ANY PART OF OUR
PRISON SYSTEM WHETHER THEIR
YARDS OR WHOLE FACILITIES ARE
CLOSING. I'M I'M GONNA ASK THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH US SO WE KNOW
WHAT'S COMING WE CAN PLAN FOR
pQUESTIONS AND WE CAN BE
RESPONSIBLE LEADERS. AND
HELPING OUR COMMUNITY TO MAKE
THE ADJUSTMENT AND SO AS I SAID
I'M GONNA BE SUPPORTING THIS
APPOINTMENT AND- AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SAY A FEW WORDS- IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO OUR COMMUNITIES
THAT THAT WE BE. PART OF THAT
THE DISCUSSION MOVING FORWARD
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU SENATOR COME BY- SENATOR
NELSON. MR PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE THIS IS A-
AN INTERESTING CHALLENGE IN AN
INTERESTING TIME DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
I CAN TELL YOU LOTS OF STORIES
ABOUT THAT ORGANIZATION AND
LET'S JUST SAY THAT IT IS LONG
BEEN DYSFUNCTIONAL IN MANY
RESPECTS AND IN MANY WAYS. BUT
MUCH OF WHAT'S BEFALLEN IT NOW
HAS THE RESPONSIBILITY. AND
ACTIONS OF GOVERNORS AND
LEGISLATORS. AND ON A FEW
OCCASIONS THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WITH PROP FORTY
SEVEN AND PROP THIRTY SIX. AND
POLICIES NOW OF JUST OPENING
THE PRISONS ALL THE JUVENILE
FACILITIES AND WASHING OUR
HANDS OF THE- PUTTING ON
REHABILITATED FELONS. IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. ANOTHER LITTLE
SMALL ITEMS. CALL THE ACTION
PROGRAM LEARNED IT PROHIBITED
PERSONS. AT THE END OF THEIR
TERM HAVING MADE THAT UP
OBLIGATION TO SOCIETY AND
JUSTICE. INDIVIDUALS FOR
CERTAIN ONES ARE PROHIBITED
FROM HAVING A GUN. BUT OUR
ATTORNEYS GENERAL I HAVE NOT
DONE ANYTHING ABOUT IT. SO THE
ISSUE WAS A BACKLOG. THOUSANDS
GOSH THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
CONFISCATED. DIDN'T HAPPEN. THE
WELL I WON'T GET INTO FURTHER
ON THAT IS KIND OF A- SOURCE
BACK WITH ME. BECAUSE NOBODY
HAS JUST ONE GUN. OR MAYBE ONLY
A FEW. BUT BACK TO THE SECTOR
CORRECTION. CLEARLY IT'S ONE OF
THE HARDEST APPOINTED JOHNSON.
IN STATE GOVERNMENT. AND I
OPPOSE CURRENT POLICIES RELATED
THERE TOO. BUT I'M NOT GONNA
ASK THIS SECRETARY. TO ANSWER
TO ME OVER THAT. IS NOT HER
CALL. AND I'M NOT INTENDING TO
VOTE FOR THE CURRENT- AGAINST
THE CONFIRMATION I MAY HAVE
STAYED. BUT I WANT TO PUT IT IN
CONTEXT THE- THAT'S A VERY
TOUGH JOB. AND THE PEOPLE IN
THAT JOB AND I UNDERSTAND SHE'S
DONE A LOT OF TIME OVER THERE.
AND I POSSIBLY BATTLE THAT
MIRACLE SHE MORE THAN ANYBODY
IN RECENT MEMORY AROUND THIS
PLACE. BUT I WOULD NOT HOLD
THAT AGAINST THIS SECRETARY.
AND YOU'LL VOTE YOUR OWN
CONSCIENCE ON IT BUT I JUST
WANTED TO GIVE YOU THE CONTEXT
IN WHICH I LOOK AT IT. THANK.
THANK YOU SENATOR NELSON ANY
OTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS APPOINTEE SENATOR GROVE.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AND I
SUPPORTED THIS OF A APPOINTMENT
OF KATHLEEN ALLISON. THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION WE RAN RULES- I
JUST. AND I KNOW THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF LITIGATION GOING ON
RIGHT NOW WITH THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY SAID THE FORTY TWO
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS HAVE FILED A
LAWSUIT AGAINST C. C. R. SHE'S
BEEN IN THIS JOB FOR LITTLE
OVER A YEAR I MEAN I THINK
MISTER DE IS JUST RETIRED IN
THE MIDST OF CODED- SHE WAS
APPOINTED THE DAY AFTER THAT
VERY NIGHT BEFORE HER
APPOINTMENT CONFIRMATION THERE
WAS A RELEASE A PRESS RELEASE
THAT WENT OUT THIS IS PRISONS
ARE GONNA CLOSE AND- I WAS MADE
AWARE OF IT WE TALKED ABOUT IT
WITH OTHER LEGISLATORS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE NORTHERN
PART OF ALLEY AND MY COLLEAGUE
FROM BEAVER. BECAUSE IT DID
AFFECT OUR DISTRICTS AND WE
WEREN'T INVOLVED IN THE
CONVERSATION- WE WERE NOT YOU
KNOW PEOPLE DON'T EVEN KNOW
ABOUT IT AND SO WE DID DISCUSS
THAT WITH HER SHE WAS A VERY
APOLOGETIC SHE SHE- SAID THAT
YOU KNOW LET'S WORK FORWARD ON
A BETTER PROCESS SO THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN AND SHE
ALSO HAD GREAT SOLUTIONS FOR
FACILITIES THAT WEREN'T- THAT
WERE NOT BEING USED BY CDC ARE
SPECIFICALLY AFFECTING MY
DISTRICT MY CALLING FROM
COUNTIES DISTRICT THAT ALLOWED.
US TO USE THOSE FACILITIES NOW
AND TURN HIM INTO SOMETHING A
BIT OFFICIAL USE FOR THE
COMMUNITY- TO BLAME HER FOR THE
THINGS THAT ARE GOING ON I
THINK IS NOT RIGHT AND THIS
ISSUE WITH RELEASING PRISONERS
AND DOWNSIZING THE PRISON
POPULATION HAS BEEN GOING ON
SINCE GOVERNOR BROWN AT LEAST-
SINCE THE TIME THAT I'VE BEEN
HERE THROUGH GOVERNOR BROWN AND
GOVERNOR NEW SEND IT STARTED
UNDER GOVERNOR BROWN I THINK IT
WAS ADDED TO BECAUSE OF THE
BUDGET LAST YEAR ON THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET WE'RE KIND OF
HEIGHT OF CO THE CRISIS. AND
THE FEDS ARE THREATENING- IF WE
DIDN'T DO DOWNSIZING- IN OUR
PRISONS THAT THEY WOULD COME IN
AND DO IT FOR US BASICALLY.
IT'S KIND OF A- MMHM. YOU KNOW.
SMALL CAPTION OF WHAT WAS
REALLY GOING ON BUT- BASICALLY
THAT WAS WHAT WAS GOING ON SO.
IT'S NOT IT'S NOT HER IT'S NOT
KATHLEEN ALLISON IS A SECRETARY
IT'S NOT HER ISSUE. AND YOU
KNOW I TALK TO PEOPLE IN A
CIVIL SHE SHOULD STAND UP TO
THE GOVERNOR WILL SHE'S PART OF
HIS CABINET SHE'S AN APPOINTEE.
AND YOU KNOW WE PASS THAT
BUDGET WE AS IN YOU KNOW ALL OF
US AND SHE'S JUST KIND OF DOING
WHAT THE BUDGET REQUIRES HER TO
DO- AND ALSO FOLLOWING THE
GOVERNORS EXECUTIVE ORDER SO.
AND WELL I SUPPORTED HER IN
THE- RULES COMMITTEE. MELISSA
THE RESUME THE CONVERSATION TO
SEE WHERE THIS GOES BUT- I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THAT IT IS NOT
KATHLEEN ALLISON'S. FAULT THAT
WE'RE IN THE SITUATION WE ARE
RIGHT NOW- WITH RELEASING
SEVENTY THOUSAND PRISONERS.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT FALLS ON
THE HEAD OF THIS ADMINISTRATION
NOT AN APPOINTEE. THAT TOOK A
POSITION LESS THAN A YEAR AGO.
THANK YOU CENTER GROVE CENTER
WINNER. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT-
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
NOMINEE- I DO JUST WANT TO FLAG
A FEW ISSUES- WHERE CITIES ARE
IS NOT DOING WHAT IT NEEDS TO
DO AND IS GOING TO BE
CONTINUING- ISSUES- THE FIRST
IS AND WE WERE WORKING WITH
CDCR AROUND THE TREATMENT OF
TRANSGENDER. PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED WE PASSED
LEGISLATION LAST YEAR TO ENSURE
THAT THEY'RE TREATED MORE
HUMANELY AND ON OUR HOUSE IN A
MORE APPROPRIATE ON MATTER THAT
CONTINUE TO BE CHALLENGES-
WITHIN CDCR IN TERMS OF
TREATMENT OF TRANS- PEOPLE- AND
STATEMENTS MADE BY GUARDS
ETCETERA ETCETERA- AND THAT IS
A CONTINUING SOURCE OF TENSION
THAT NEEDS TO BE RESOLVE I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE SECRETARY ON THAT. ON WE
ALSO SEE SHARKS CONTINUES TO
FACILITATE TRANSFERS OF PEOPLE
TO OUR USE WHEN THEY'RE
RELEASED THEY'VE DONE THEIR
TIME THEY'VE PAID THEIR PRICE
TO THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THEN CITY STARS
FACILITATING THEIR DEPORTATION-
THAT NEEDS TO STOP WE CALLING
ON CITY STARTED US CUT IT OUT
TO STOP THERE'S NO LEGISLATION
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARDIO TO DO
THAT- BUT THESE ARE CONTINUING
PROBLEMS THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE SECRETARY- TO
MOVE TO A BETTER PLACE. THANK
YOU SENATOR ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
APPOINTEE. ANY OTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SENATOR LAYERED
THING YOU FOR GIVING A GETTING
US OFF TO A BIGGER START THE
WEEK WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ON
THIS APPOINTEE. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT LET ME JUST SAY THAT
I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS OF
ALL OUR COLLEAGUES. N. AFTER
THE HEARING OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE. BASED ON A LOT OF
THESE COMMENTS WE SUBMITTED A
SECOND ROUND OF QUESTIONS TO
THE SECRETARY AND SHE RESPONDED
AND SHE DEALT WITH. AS THE
SENATOR FROM BIEBER SAID MANY
OF THE ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED
IN A WAY THAT I THINK WAS
HELPFUL AND SHE COMMITTED TO
WORK WITH US OVER TIME. ON
THESE ISSUES I THINK SHE'S A
GOOD APPOINTMENT I ASK FOR YOUR
I. PHONE. THANK YOU SENATOR
LAYERED SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
AT KINS HI BASE I BECKER. HI
FOR JUST FIVE BRADFORD HI BY
ADAM HI COURTESY. DALLY DOT HI
THERE I WASN'T HI EGGMAN HI
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ. GROWTH
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER.
LAYERED I LLEVA HI THE MON I
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S. MAN HI
NEWMAN. NIELSEN I A SHOW OF
BOTH I PAN. FIVE FORTUNE TINO I
BROUGHT. HI RUBIO. SKINNER I
STERN I AM BERG I LIKE HOW SKI
I WINNER. I WILL HI SINNER
LAYERED MOVES A CALL MEMBERS
ARE GONNA MOVE ON A FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE- GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEE CENTER LAYERED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- ITEM THREE IS
THE CONFIRMATION OF GEAR MOLE
VIEIRA ROCHA AS DIRECTOR OF THE
DIVISION OF ADULT PAROLE
OPERATIONS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
MR VIA ROSA HAS EXTENSIVE
EXPERIENCE IN THE PAROLE SYSTEM
HAVING PREVIOUSLY SERVED IN
THIS ROLE AND AS A PAROLE
ADMINISTRATOR A DEPUTY PAROLE
COMMISSIONER AND A PAROLE AGENT
HE WAS APPROVED BY THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE ON A FIVE OH
VOTE I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE. THANK YOU CENTER LED
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS APPOINTEE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI AT
KINS I FACE NO BECKER. I
PORCHES HI BRADFORD HI BY ADAM
HI COURTESY I DALLY. DOT HI
DERISIVE HI EGGMAN HI GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATES GROWTH. HERTZBERG
I WAS SO. HI HER TADO HI JONES
I CAN LONGER. LAYERED IVE
LABOR I THE MON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. CONTROL OF BOTH HI PAM
FIVE PERSON YOU KNOW HI RALPH
HI RUBIO. HI SKINNER. STERN HI
AMBER HI FORECASTING HI WINNER
I WILL HI SINNER LED MOVES THE
CALL WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON ITEM
NUMBER FOUR CENTER LAYERED
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR PRESIDENT I AM
FORCED TO CONFIRMATION OF
RONALD DAVIS AS ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR RECEPTION CENTER
INSTITUTIONS AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION HE BEGAN HIS
CAREER AT CDC ARE IN NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR MOST RECENTLY HE
SERVED AS WARDEN OF THE SAN
QUENTIN STATE PRISON HE WAS
APPROVED BY THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON A FOUR ZERO VOTE I
ASK FOR YOUR I. PHONE. THANK
YOU SIR LET MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
APPOINTEE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI AT. I BASE HI
BECKER. I PORCHES HI BRADFORD I
COME BY IT- HI CORTESE I DALLY.
GOD. HI TORONTO HI EGGMAN. I
LASER I GONZALEZ GROVE HI HERZ
BERG I WAS SO HYPER TIDO I
JONES I CAN LONGER. LAYERED I
LLEVA I LIVE ALONE I REQUIRE.
HI MELINDA'S I MEN HI NEWMAN I
NELSON. A SHOW OF BOTH. HI PAM
I FORTUNE TINO HI ROTH FIVE
RUBIO. HI SKINNER I STERN I AM
BERG I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER. I
WILL. HI SINNER LAYERED MOVES A
CALL THIS CONCLUDES THE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES FOR TODAY
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
THE SENATE THIRD READING WE'RE
GOING TO PICK UP I. F. FILE AND
I'M TWELVE FIRST FOLLOWED BY. A
FINAL ITEM FOURTEEN. FILE ITEM
TWELVE IS S. C. R. FORTY FIVE
BY SENATOR DODD SENATOR DODD
APPEARS TO BE READY SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FORTY FIVE BY
SENATOR DODD AND RELATIVE TO
ELDER AND DEPENDENT ADULT ABUSE
AWARENESS MONTH SENATOR DODD.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
YES C. R. FORTY FIVE SEEKS TO
RECOGNIZE THE MONTH OF JUNE IS
ELDER AND VULNERABLE ADULT
ABUSE AWARENESS MONTH. THE
ANNUAL RECOGNITION ALIGNS WITH
NATIONAL AND INTERNATIONAL
RECOGNITION DURING THE MONTH OF
JUNE. SADLY NEARLY ONE IN TEN
AMERICANS SIXTY YEARS OF AGE
AND OLDER EXPERIENCE ABUSE EACH
YEAR THE ELDERLY INDEPENDENT
ADULTS MAY BE IMPACTED BY A
CONSTELLATION OF PHYSICAL
MENTAL PHARMACEUTICAL OR
MEDICAL INCLUDES INFLUENCES ANY
OF WHICH COULD RESTRICT THE
ABILITY TO PROTECT THEMSELVES
OR TO REPORT TO AUTHORITIES
WHEN THIS BUSE OCCURS. HOWEVER
EDUCATING OURSELVES ABOUT THIS
PROBLEM IN ORDER TO RECOGNIZE
THE SIGNS OF ABUSE IS THE FIRST
STEP TOWARDS PREVENTION
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR DOT IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE CULTURAL. ALAN
HI ARCHULETA I AT KINS HI BABES
I BACKER. HI FOR JUST I
BRADFORD HI BYRON I COURTESY I
DALLY. I DON I TORONTO HI
EGGMAN I BELIEVE HER. FIVE
DOLLARSGROVE. FIVE HERTZBERG.
WITH SO HI HER TADO HI JONES I
CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LABOR. I
LIVE ALONE I REQUIRE. FIVE
MELINDA'S FIVE MEN I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN. I A SHOW OF BOTH HI
CAN I FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH I
REVIEW I SKINNER. I STERN I AM
BERG I WHAT KIND OF SKI. I
WINNER. HI WELL HI SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GONZALEZ HERTZBERG HI. THEIR
DAUGHTERS THE CALL- MOVING ON
NEXT TO FILE ITEM FOURTEEN WILL
BE FOLLOWED BY SIXTEEN FILE AND
FOURTEEN IS SENATOR MCGUIRE
WITH S. C. R. FORTY EIGHT.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FORTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR MCGUIRE
RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA GROWN
FLOWER MONTH. THEY REQUIRE
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT IN HAPPY MONDAY TO
SIMPLY TO PRESENT S. C. R.
FORTY EIGHT WOULD RECOGNIZE IS
THE MONTH OF JUNE AS CALIFORNIA
GROWNFARM ON YOU KNOW IT'S
BEEN THE PAST HALF CENTURY
WHERE CALIFORNIA FARMERS HAVE
WORKED AT THE GOLDEN STATE'S
FURTER FERTILE SOILS. IN WE ARE
OF COURSE AMERICA'S NUMBER ONE
FARM STATE AND CALIFORNIA
FLOWER GROWERS ACCOUNT 475% 75%
OF ALL DOMESTICALLY GROWN CUT
FLOWERS MEETING THE STRICTEST
GROWING STANDARDS IN THE WORLD
HUMBLE COUNTY IN THE CENTRAL
COAST ONE OF THE LARGEST FLOWER
PRODUCERS IN CALIFORNIA ARE IN
UP IN HUMBLE COUNTY WERE KNOWN
FOR. GROWING AT TWO LOOKS
LOUISE AND IRIS AND IN FACT A
FUN FACT FOR EACH AND EVERYONE
OF YOU THE LARGEST PRODUCING
REGION OR FRESH CUT TULIPS
UNITED STATES IN THE BIRTHPLACE
OF THE LEGENDARY STARGAZER LILY
ARCADIA CALIFORNIA THE TOTAL
ECONOMIC IMPACT OF CALIFORNIA
GROWN FLOWERS WHOLESALERS AND
RETAIL FLORISTS EXCEEDS TWELVE
BILLION DOLLARS BUT LIKE MANY
INDUSTRIES OVER THE LAST YEAR
AND A HALF. DURING THE PANDEMIC
THE GOLDEN STATE'S FLOWER
FARMERS HAVE BEEN HIT HARD SO
THE NEXT TIME YOU BUY FLOWERS
LOOK FOR THE BLUE AND GOLD
CALIFORNIA GROWN LICENSE PLATE
LOGO EVEN THOUGH THOSE FLOWERS
ARE GROWN RIGHT HERE IN THE
GOLDEN STATE BY A LOCAL FARMER
PLEASE JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING
JUNE OF THIS MONTH. JUNE OF
THIS YEAR AS CALIFORNIA GROWN
FLOWER MONTH RESPECTFULLY. ASK
FOR AN ITEM. THANK YOU SIR
MCGUIRE ANY DISK OR TO ON THE
ITEM SEND LAMONT. AND THANK YOU
TO MY COLLEAGUE AND FOR
PRESENTING THIS AS A SOMEONE
WHO REPRESENT 75% OF CALIFORNIA
HAD GROWN FLOWERS IN THE
DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT I
WANTED TO ALSO RAISE- AND TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW
IMPORTANT THIS IS TO THE
DISTRICT BUT ALSO TO THE
FAMILIES A LOT OF THE FAMILIES-
THAT FARM. THESE FLOWERS HAVE
BEEN- IN OUR COMMUNITY FOR
GENERATIONS AND DO SUCH
INCREDIBLE WORKING. TO ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE KNOW THE IMPORTANCE%
OF BUYING CALIFORNIA FLOWERS
ESPECIALLY AS WE'RE SEEING A
DEMAND FOR INTERNATIONAL
FLOWERS SO I WANT TO THINK AT
MY COLLEAGUE FOR RICK RAISING
THIS AND ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
HOW IMPORTANT THIS IS. NOT JUST
AS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
SENATE DISTRICT NINETEEN. THANK
YOU CENTER LET ALONE ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CENTER
MCGUIRE WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU SO MUCH ALWAYS A
GREAT FOR THE WORK FROM THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM THE CENTRAL
COAST IN FOR HER LEADERSHIP IS
WELL- AND MR PRESIDENT IN THE
HALLWAY YOU'RE GOING TO FIND A
FLOWER BOUQUET COMPLIMENTS OF
THE CALIFORNIA CUT FLOWER
COMMISSION. AND AGAIN GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR SUPPORT A CALIFORNIA
GROWN FARM THANK YOU SCHERING
WHERE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA. I.
ATKINS. I BASE I BECKER SORRY
FOR JUST I BRADFORD HI BY ADAM
I COURTESY I DALLY. I DONT HI
THE RUSSELL HI A COMMON I
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ GROVE. HI
HURTS BERG I WAS SO. I HER TADO
I JONES FIVE KM LONGER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA. I THE MON I
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S I MEN HI
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN I A SHOW OF
VOGUE I CAN. HI FORTUNE TINO HI
ROTH HI RUBIO HI SKINNER FIVE
STERN I AM BERG I LIKE HOW SKI
I WINNER. FIVE WELL I SENATOR
MCGUIRE MOVES A CALL MEMBERS
ARE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN WHICH WILL BE FOLLOWD
BY SEVENTEEN FILE AN M. SIXTEEN
IS SENATOR RUBIO WITH SR THIRTY
SIX CENTER RUBIO'S READY
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
RESOLUTION THIRTY SIX BY
SENATOR RUBIO RELATIVE TO LUPUS
AWARENESS MONTH. SENATOR RUBIO
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT SR
THIRTY SIX WHICH BECAME MAY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AS LUPUS
AWARENESS MONTH LUPUS IS A
COMPLEX AND OFTEN LIFE
THREATENING AUTO IMMUNE DISEASE
IN THE UNITED STATES THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY FIVE I'M SORRY
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND TO ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION PEOPLE
DIAGNOSED WITH LUPUS WELL THESE
DISEASES AFFECT PEOPLE OF ALL
AGES 90% OF LUPUS PATIENTS ARE
WOMEN AND WOMEN OF COLOR ARE AT
HIGHER RISK. THERE IS NO CURE
FOR LUPUS AND THERE HAVE ONLY
BEEN TWO DRUGS APPROVED TO
TREAT LUPUS IN THE PAST SIXTY
YEARS S. R. THIRTY SIX WILL
HELP EXPAND PUBLIC AWARENESS
AND EDUCATION WITH THE HOPE OF
PROVIDING PATIENTS WITH BETTER
TREATMENT I WANT TO THANK
QUANAH MOCKED THEM A FRIEND A
CONSTITUENT FROM MY DISTRICT
WHO WAS DIAGNOSED WITH LUPUS
AND CREATED THE LUPUS BALLOONS
FOR LUPUS ORGANIZATION ALONG
WITH HER FAMILY AND HAS TAKEN
AN ACTIVE ROLE IN EDUCATING AND
REALLY TRYING TO FIND A CURE SO
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO ANY. DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HE
DISCUSSION. SEEING NONE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I
FACE. I BACKER I PORCHES HI
BRADFORD I HAVE A I DON'T I
COURTESY HI DALLY. I DON HI
THERE ALSO HI EGGMAN. GLAZER I
GONZALEZ. GROVE FIVE HURTS BERG.
I WAS SO. HI HER TADO I JONES I
CAN LONGER. I LAYERED I. LEIVA.
HI THE MON HI WIRE I MELINDA'S
I MEN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN BY A
SHOW OF BOTH I PAM I FORTUNE
TINO. I BROUGHT I REVIEW I
SKINNER I STERN. HI NUMBER FIVE
BY CAL SKI I WINNER I WILL. HI
SENATOR RUBIO MOVES A CALL
MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON A FILE
ITEM SEVENTEEN WHICH WILL BE
FOLLOWED BY EIGHTEEN FILE AND
SEVENTEEN AS SENATOR RUBIO WITH
S. R. THIRTY SEVEN. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE RESOLUTION
THIRTY SEVEN BY SENATOR RUBIO
RELATIVE TO FIBROMYALGIA
AWARENESS MONTH SENATOR RUBIO
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE I
RISE TO PRESENT SR THIRTY SEVEN
WHICH COULD KEEP THINGS MAY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AS
FIBROMYALGIA AWARENESS MONTH
FIBROMYALGIA IS A CHRONIC
ILLNESS THAT CAN CAUSE FATIGUE
COGNITIVE PROBLEMS AND THE
ABILITY IN PAIN AND THE UNITED
STATES THERE ARE OVER FORTY
FOUR MILLION PEOPLE DIAGNOSED
WITH FIBROMYALGIA AND THERE IS
NO CURE AND BECAUSE OF THE LACK
OF UNDERSTANDING AND SOCIAL
ACCEPTANCE MANY OF ITS
PATIENTS. FACE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES. S. R. THIRTY SEVEN
WILL HELP EXPAND PUBLIC
AWARENESS AND EDUCATION AND I
WANT TO THINK- A CONSTITUENT OF
FRIEND OF MINE IS THAT I'M NOT
DONE AGAIN FROM MY DISTRICT WHO
WAS DIAGNOSED WITH FIBROMYALGIA
AND HELPED. FORM THE
FIBROMYALGIA AND THAT WORK AND
AGAIN HAS TKEN AN ACTIVE ROLE
IN TRYING TO FIND A CURE I WANT
TO THANK ALL THE BIPARTISAN CO
AUTHORS WHO HAVE JOINED ME IN
SUPPORTING THIS. IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR RIVAL THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN FIVE ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I
BASE I BACKER I PORCHES I
BRADFORD HI BY ADAM HI COURTESY
HI DALLY. I DONT I TORONTO HI
EGGMAN I GLAZER. I CONSOLIDATE.
GROWTH HI HURTS BERG. I WAS SO.
I HER TADO HI JONES I CAN
LONGER I LAYERED I LLEVA HI THE
MON I REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S.
FIVE MEN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN I A
SHOW OF BOTH HI PAM HI FORTUNE
TINO HI RALPH HI RUBIO. I
SKINNER I STERN I AM BERG I
WAKE OUT SKI I WINNER. I WILL.
HI SENATOR RUBIO MOVES A CALL
MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON A FILE
AND I'M EIGHTEEN S. R. THIRTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR JOE BOWEN
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
RESOLUTION THIRTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR OCHO OF BOTH RELATIVE
TO MUSIC CHANGING LIVES MONTH.
MR JONES. MR PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK SENATE
RESOLUTION THIRTY EIGHT
DECLARES THE MONTH OF MAY AS
MUSIC CHANGING LIVES MOM MUSIC
BENEFITS INDIVIDUALS OF ALL
AGES WHETHER IT BE FROM PLAYING
AN INSTRUMENT SINGING OR SIMPLY
LISTENING MUSIC BENEFITS
INDIVIDUALS OF ALL AGES WHETHER
IT BE FROM PLAYING AN
INSTRUMENT SINGING OR SIMPLY
LISTENING IT HAS A UNIQUE
IMPACTS SPECIALLY FOR CHILDREN
AND TEENS. MUSICALS OF THE
IMAGINATION DEVELOP THIRD
LANGUAGE SKILLS IT CAN BE
THERAPEUTIC. AND I CAN SPEAK
PERSONALLY- FROM PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE FROM MY CHILDREN
WHO. HAVE MADE MUSIC- AS PART
OF THEIR DEVELOPMENT AND I CAN
TELL YOU THAT HE HAS BROUGHT
FAMILY TOGETHERNESS IT HAS
BUILT UP THEIR ABILITY TO
CONVEY THEIR EMOTIONS AND
ACTUALLY HELP THEM EVEN IN
THEIR ACADEMICS. MUSIC CHANGING
LIFE IS A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION FROM MY DISTRICT
THAT PROVIDES INSTRUCTION IN
MUSIC AND ART AFTER SCHOOL
TUTORING MENTORING INSTRUCTION
IN FINANCIAL LITERACY AND
CULTURAL EXPERIENCES TO
STUDENTS ACROSS SAN BERNADINO
AND RIVERSIDE COUNTIES. SINCE
ITS START MUSIC CHANGING LIFE
HAS BEEN DEDICATED TO ENSURING
EDUCATIONAL AND CAREER SUCCESS
FOR STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. THIS
DYNAMIC ORGANIZATION IN PARIS
ARE YOU TO FIND IN RICHMOND IN
THEIR EDUCATION WHICH IMPROVES
OUR CHANCES OF ACHIEVING A
POSITIVE AND SUCCESSFUL FUTURE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR JOE
BOGEY ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM MEMBERS SENATOR
HERTZBERG. MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
IS C. SIGNIFICANTLY IN DEEPLY
PROUD FATHER OF A SON WHO'S A
CLASSICAL MUSIC COMPOSER. I
WILL TELL YOU THAT HIS MUSIC IS
CHANGED MY LIFE I ASKED FOR AND
I HAVE A- THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG ANY OTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI I.
ARCHULETA I AT KINS I BASE I
BECKER. HI PORGES HI BRADFORD I
COULD ADAM ARE YOU PROTESTING I
DALLY. I DON I TORONTO I EGGMAN
I GLAZER. GONZALEZ GROVE. HI
HURTS BERG HI I WAS SO. I HER
TADO. JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LLEVA I LIVE ALONE HI
WHERE. I MELINDA'S I MEN. I
NEWMAN. NIELSEN I SHOW BOTH I
PAN HI I. FORTUNE TINO I. ROSS.
HI RUBIO I SKINNER HI I. STERN
I AM BERG I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER HI WELL I. THIS CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS GLAZER HI.
GONZALEZ HER TADO. NEWMAN I IN
OUR TROUBLED MOVES A CALL
MEMBERS THAT CONCLUDES. OUR
FILE ITEMS FOR TODAY WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS WISHING TO BE
RECOGNIZED FOR MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. SENATOR MELINDA'S.
SEVERAL IT IS FOR A PURPOSE DO
YOU WRITE. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE PURSUANT TO
SENATE RULE TWENTY EIGHT I'M
MAKING A MOTION TO WITHDRAW
ESSERE FIVE FROM THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE. AND BROUGHT TO THE
SENATE FLOOR SO WE CAN HAVE A
FULL AND VIGOROUS DEBATE IT HAS
BEEN FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE
DAYS NOW. SINCE THE GOVERNOR
DECLARED A STATE OF EMERGENCY
SINCE THAT TIME EVERY
CALIFORNIAN WHO WANTS A
VACCINATION CAN RECEIVE ONE-
OUR CABIN DEATH RATE IS
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS THAN THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE AS IS THE CASE
RATE. AND DURING THE LAST
FIFTEEN MONTHS THE LEGISLATURE
LARGELY HAS BEEN- CUT OUT OF
THE DISCUSSIONS IN PROCESS
SEES- ON THE DECISIONS THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS BEEN MAKING THIS
BODY HAS BEEN- NEUTERED
ESSENTIALLY AND I THINK IT'S
TIME. FOR THE LEGISLATURE BUT
THE LEGISLATURE STEPPED BACK
INTO ITS APPROPRIATE ROLE. IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH RATHER THAN BEING FORCED
INTO BEING SUBORDINATE TO THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH SO WITH THAT.
I ASK FOR YOUR ITEM. THANK YOU
SENATOR MELINDA SENATOR
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR PRESIDENT MAJORITY
RESTAURANT OVER. THANK YOU SIR
HERS BERG SENATOR MELINDA S
ASKING FOR AN I. VOTE SENATOR
HERTZBERG IS ASKING FOR A NO
VOTE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN NO ARCHULETA. NO
ATKINS. NO BASE HI BACKER. NO
PORGES HI BRADFORD. NO BY ADAM
NO CORTEZ HE NO DALLY. I DONT.
NO THEY'RE AWESOME. NO EGGMAN
NO GLAZER NO GUNS ALLAH'S NO
GROWTH I HURTS BERG. NO WAY SO.
WHAT IS SO. NO HER TADO NO
JONES I CAN LONGER. NO LAYERED
NO LLEVA. NO LIVE MON. WELL
KNOWN. NO MCGUIRE NO MELINDA'S
I MEN NO NEWMAN NO NIELSEN I A
SHOW OF BOTH I CAN. NO PARTY
TINO NO ROSS NO RUBIO. NO
SKINNER. NO STERN NO AMBERG NO
WAY CASKEY NO WE- NO WELL. HI I
NINE KNOWS THIRTY ONE THE
MOTION FAILS MEMBERS WERE GONNA
GO BACK AND LIFT THE CALL ON A
PREVIOUS ITEMS. M. SECRETARY WE
CAN MOVE. AND THAT MEANS YEAH.
MEMBERS WILL HAVE THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM TO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CORTEZ
THREE. DOW GONZALEZ I GROWTH I.
CAN LONGER. MELINDA'S. NEWMAN
RUBIO. HI. I THIRTY FIVE NO
ZERO THE. IS CONFIRM WITH ON A
FILE AND THREE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEE SECRETARY PLEASE THE
ROLL. TALLY. GONZALEZ I GROVE I.
CAN LONGER. I K. CAN LONGER I
DON'T KNOW. MELINDA'S. NIELSEN
SKINNER I. SENATOR BATES WHAT.
CENTER BATES NOTIFY. BATES NOTE
I'D AND SUNDERLAND. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DALLY.
MELINDA'S NIELSEN. HIGHS THIRTY
SIX KNOWS ONE THE APPOINTMENT
IS CONFIRMED FILE ITEM FOR
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. DALLY HI
HI. GONZALEZ I CAN LONGER.
NIELSEN. HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED MOVING ON TO FILE AN
M. TWELVE S. C. R. FORTY FIVE
BY SENATOR DODD SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. GONZALEZ
I HIGHS FORTY KNOWS NO ITEM
PASSES BUT ITEM FOURTEEN AS C.
R. FORTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. GONZALEZ AYE. AYES
FORTINOS NO ITEM PASSES MOVING
ON TO FILE AN M. SIXTEEN S. R.
THIRTY SIX BY SENATOR RUBIO
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I COMMEND I GONZALEZ HI GUYS
FORTINOS NO NOT ZERO ITEM
PASSES MOVING ON A FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN AT ZERO THIRTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR RUBIO SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. GONZALEZ
I. HIGHS. FORTY KNOWS ZERO ITEM
PASSES AT ZERO THIRTY EIGHT
WELL I AM EIGHTEEN BY SENATOR
TROUBLED. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GONZALEZ I HER TADO. HIGHS
THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO ITEM
PASSES MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON
TO COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS WE
HAVE CENTER CORTESE WITH ONE
ANNOUNCEMENT FOR COMMITTEES.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT LABOR
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT-
WILL MEET IMMEDIATELY UPON THE
GERMAN ROOM FOR TWO OR THREE
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
CORTESE MEMBERS WERE GONNA MOVE
BACK TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
FOR THE PURPOSE OF A GERMAN
MEMORIES. WE HAVE TO A GERMAN
MEMORIES THIS AFTERNOON WE'RE
GONNA RECOGNIZE SENATOR
CABALLERO FIRST SENATOR CAFIERO.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY TO ASK THE SENATE
TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMBER MEMORY
OF MARIE THERESE THEM RALPH
GALLO. RE GALLO WAS A BELOVED
PHILANTHROPIST AN ACTIVE
COMMUNITY MEMBER THAT EMBODIED
SELFLESSNESS GENEROSITY AND
COMPASSION AS A MOTHER
DEDICATED WIFE AND YOU MONETARY
AND- SHE GREW UP BUT IN MODESTO
AS A DAUGHTER OF A PROMINENT
JUDGE WHO INSTILLED IN HER THE
IMPORTANCE OF A LOVING FAMILY.
DEVOTION TO HER FAITH IN GOD
AND HELPING OTHERS THROUGH
CIVIC RESPONSIBILITY WHICH
BECAME THE GUIDING PRINCIPLE
THAT SHE FOLLOWED FOR HER
ENTIRE LIFE. SHE HAD THE MEANS
AND ABILITY TO GO ANYWHERE IN
THE WORLD BUT SHE DID DECIDED
TO REMAIN IN OUR HOME TOWN
WHERE SHE MET HER HUSBAND MR
BOB GALLO. TOGETHER THEY RAN A
SUCCESSFUL WINERY AND BUILT A
BEAUTIFUL FAMILY RAISING EIGHT
CHILDREN AND TWENTY TWO GRAND
CHILDREN. MARIE GALLO EARNED
HER BACHELOR OF ARTS DEGREE
WITH A TEACHING CREDENTIAL AT
NOTRE DAME DIMMER THE NUMBER
UNIVERSITY IN BELMONT
CALIFORNIA UPON RETURNING TO
MODESTO AFTER COLLEGE MARIE
GALLO WENT ON TO TEACH FOURTH
GRADE AT THE ST. ST STANISLAUS
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL AS A TEACHER
AND A CHAMPION FOR EDUCATION
SHE MADE SURE THAT EVERY
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL STUDENT IN
MODESTO HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
VISIT THE REGION'S
ENVIRONMENTAL SANCTUARIES TO
LEARN ABOUT THE WORLD THAT THEY
LIVE IN. READ HELLO HAVE A
GREAT PASSION FOR THE ARTS SHE
BEGAN HER STUDENT STUDIES AT A
VERY YOUNG AGE AND FELL IN LOVE
WITH PLAYING THE PIANO. SHE
STUDIED UNDER MODESTO MUSIC
ICON FRANK NANCY ANNE MARIE
GALLO BECAME A CELEBRATED
MUSICIAN AS A CLASSICALLY
TRAINED PIANIST AND MUSIC
TEACHER PERHAPS THE MOST
EXCEPTIONAL REPRESENTATION OF
WHO MARIE GALLO WAS IS SEEN
THROUGH HER ADVOCACY WORK ON
BEHALF OF THE GALLO CENTER FOR
THE ARTS. IN INTERNATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED CULTURAL CENTER FOR
THE PERFORMING ARTS BECAUSE OF
THE ORGANIZATIONAL LEADERSHIP.
OF MARIE GALLO THE FAMILY
GENEROUSLY FUNDED THE CENTER'S
DESIGN CONSTRUCTION AND
ENDOWMENT TO ENSURE THAT IT
WOULD PROVIDE FUTURE
GENERATIONS. IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY WITH A QUALITY
ENTERTAINMENT OPPORTUNITY. THE
GALLO SENATE SENT- HOSTED AT TO
TWO DOLLAR PEOPLE ANNUALLY
RIGHTFULLY EARNING ITS PLACE AS
THE ENTERTAINMENT HUB OF THE
CITY OF MODESTO AND THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY. MARIE GALLO
SERVED AS A MEMBER ON A NUMBER
OF BOARDS THAT SUPPORTED LOCAL
ARTS ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING
THE STANISLAVSKY MISSION THE
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA ARTS
ASSOCIATION AND THE EDUCATION
FOUNDATION OF STANISLAUS
COUNTY. HER STRONG DEVOTION TO
HER FAITH ELEVATED HER AS A
RELIGIOUS LEADER IN THE
COMMUNITY SHE WAS A DEVOTED
MEMBER OF THE DAUGHTERS OF
CHARITY FOUNDATION BOARD. THREE
SHE CHAMPIONED FUNDING HEALTH
EDUCATIONAL AND RELIGIOUS
MINISTRIES. IN RECOGNITION OF
HER MANY ACHIEVEMENTS MARIE
GALLO WAS HONORED WITH NUMEROUS
AWARDS INCLUDING THE LIBERTY
BELL AWARD FROM THE STANISLAUS
COUNTY BAR ASSOCIATION. THE
TORCH OF LIBERTY AWARD FROM THE
ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE. THE
OUTSTANDING WOMAN OF THE YEAR
AWARD BY THE STANISLAUS COUNTY
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND THE BISHOPS AWARD
FROM THE DIOCESE OF STOCKTON
JUST TO NAME A FEW. SHE IS. HER
PHILANTHROPY ALLOWED SEVERAL
POST SECONDARY INSTITUTIONS TO
DREAM A LITTLE BIGGER RESEARCH
MORE AND SOLVE FUTURE ISSUES.
THREE GALLO WILL BE REMEMBERED
AS A RELIGIOUS WOMAN WHO GAVE
QUIETLY GET. GENEROUSLY HE
LEAVES BEHIND A LEGACY THAT
UPLIFTS THE SPIRIT OF
INNOVATION CALIFORNIA IS KNOWN
BY. GALERA SURF VIBE BY HER
HUSBAND OF SIXTY THREE YEARS
BOB GALLO SEVEN CHILDREN HER
BROTHER AND TWENTY TWO GRAND
CHILDREN THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT THE
SENATE INJURED IN HER MEMORY.
THANK YOU SENATOR CAFIERO
SENATE CHAIRMAN. COLLEAGUES
TODAY I RISE TO ASK THIS BODY
TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF AID AND
ANTHONY LEO'S. YOU MAY HAVE
READ ABOUT. IT IN THIS TRAGIC
MURDER. A COUPLE WEEKS AGO ON
MAY TWENTY FIRST HE WAS
TRAGICALLY TAKEN FROM US AT THE
VERY YOUNG AGE OF SIX. BY HIS
MOTHER IS DRIVING IN THE
KINDERGARTEN THE FIFTY FIVE IN
ORANGE. AGENT WAS MURDERED IN A
HEINOUS ACT OF ROAD RAGE IN GUN
VIOLENCE. THIS MURDER WAS A
RANDOM AND SENSELESS. YESTERDAY
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
ARRESTED TWO SUSPECTS BELIEVED
TO BE RESPONSIBLE FOR AIDEN'S
DEATH. I KNOW THAT THE FAMILY
IS ENCOURAGED THAT JUSTICE MAY
BE SERVED BUT THAT OF COURSE
WILL NOT BRING BACK YOUNG AIDEN.
HIS DEATH HAS ROCKED OUR ORANGE
COUNTY COMMUNITY. AND IT IS
VERY PERSONAL FOR ME. I DRIVE
THAT SECTION OF ROAD VERY OFTEN
MYSELF IN FACT I JUST DROVE IT
WITH MY KIDS OVER THE WEEKEND.
I HAVE A FIVE YEAR OLD WHO
STARTS KINDERGARTEN THIS FALL
AND THAT COULD HAVE BEEN MY
PAXTON. IT COULD'VE BEEN YOUR
KID OR GRANTED IT COULD BE ANY
ONE OF US. THIS RANDOM ACTS OF
VIOLENCE TOOK FROM US A SWEET
KIND BOY WHO IS BELOVED BY ALL
WHO KNEW HIM. I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF SPEAKING WITH
AGENTS FAMILY YESTERDAY. AND
WAS SO TOUCHED TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT THIS INCREDIBLE YOUNG BOY.
HE WAS AN ANGEL. GET A TENDER
GIVING HEART AND HELPFUL NATURE
ALWAYS ASKING WHAT HE COULD DO
TO HELP. EIGHT WAS A SELFLESS
CHILD WITH A BIG HEART FOR
OTHER KIDS AND ANIMALS. HE
LOVED BUGS AND INSECTS AND TOLD
HIS PARENTS HE DREAMED ABOUT
GROWING UP TO BECOME AN
ENTOMOLOGIST. HE ALSO LOVED
MUSIC AND DINOSAURS AND OF
COURSE LIKE ALL OTHER SIX YEAR
OLD BOYS I THINK. HE WAS ALL
ABOUT POKEMON AND COULD TALK
YOUR EAR OFF ABOUT CHAR'S ARDS
AND LEGENDARY POKEMON. AND ALL
THE OTHER STUFF THAT US ADULTS
CANNOT BEGIN TO UNDERSTAND.
LIKE ANY OTHER SIX YEAR OLD HE
WAS EXCITED BECAUSE HE JUST
RECEIVED A NINTENDO SWITCH
WHICH WAS HOLDING. WHEN HE
PASSED. MOST OF ALL HE LOVED
HUMANITY AND WAS FILLED WITH
JOY LOVE AND KINDNESS. HE WAS
THOUGHTFUL AND CARING ABOUT
OTHERS AND ONLY WANTED TO SEE
THE HAPPINESS THAT OTHERS COULD
BRING TO THIS WORLD. RECENTLY
HIS MOTHER TOOK HIM TO A PARK.
WHERE THEY'RE BUNCH OF CHILDREN
PLAYING. WHEN A CHILD WAS
APPARENTLY ARTISTIC. AND
FLINGING HIS BODY ON THE FLOOR
AND SCREAMING I DON'T WANT TO
TALK. THE OTHER KIDS ALL NOR
THIS YOUNG CHILD BUT EIGHT IN
ALONE WENT OVER TO HIM. KNELT
DOWN AND SAID YOU DON'T HAVE TO
TALK. AND THEN OFFERED IN HIS
HAND. AND THIS WAS THE TYPE OF
HUMAN BEING THAT EIGHT AND
ONCE. HE WAS KIND THOUGHTFUL
AND SO LOVING TO OTHERS. WE
HAVE LOST THAT LIGHT AND ALL OF
THE POTENTIAL HE HELD. TO DO
THIS RANDOM ACT OF VIOLENCE AND
ANGER. OUR HEARTS BREAK FOR THE
LOSS SUFFERED BY AIDEN'S FATHER
JOEY. IS MOTHER JOANNA. HIS
SISTER ALEXIS AND ALL THOSE WHO
KNEW HIM AND WERE TOUCHED BY
THE LIGHT AND KINDNESS THAT
AIDEN BROUGHT TO THIS WORLD.
ORANGE COUNTY IS A WORSE PLACE
BECAUSE OF THE LOSS OF IT IN
THE US. THE WORLD IS WORSE OFF
BECAUSE OF THE LOSS TAKING THE
US. AND I RESPECT YES SIR. WITH
THIS BODY DURING THE STAY IN
MEMORY OF A- AND THAT WE KEEP
HIS MEMORY IN OUR HEARTS
ALWAYS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR MEN MEN SID- MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES FORWARD
SO THIS CAN BE PROPERLY
MINERALIZED BY THE- SENATE AND
PLEASE SHARE CONDOLENCES WITH
BOTH FAMILIES THANK YOU. IF
THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS
SENATOR RECKONS THE DESK IS
CLEAR. MR PRESIDENT THANK YOU
SO MUCH OUR NEXT FLOOR SESSION
IS SCHEDULED FOR THURSDAY JUNE
TENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT NINE
AM THANK YOU FOR. THANK YOU SIR
RECKONS THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM AT
WHICH TIME THE GERMAN MOTION
WILL BE PLACED. MEMBERS WE WILL
RECONVENE ON THURSDAY AT NINE
AM THANK YOU AND HAVE A GREAT
DAY.